a lot of the hacks that we did were very
simple in the sense that it wasn't
really to show that we were Master
hackers but more that the companies that
we were hacking had very poor security
so there's there's a few very common
hacking vulnerabilities that were quite
common at the time one of them is for
example called SQL injection which is to
do with the way that a website is
programmed and how it accesses its
internal database and if it's not
programmed correctly then you can
basically hack the entire database and
change things so when you hack a
company's database you might come across
passwords and when you crack those
passwords you might find out that people
are using the same password everywhere
so for example with one company we
hacked um their CEO was using the same
password for his email company account
his Paypal account His World of Warcraft
account and pretty much every single
account so we managed to get access to
his entire online life because he was
using the same password
[Music]
everywhere